the wand division actress has recently
risen to fame and become a household
name
but the fact is she's been on our
screens for nearly 20 years
why did she contradict the fact that
she's been acting since she was a child
what easter egg to her past is hidden in
wandavision
let's check it out then where are the
twins before there was elizabeth olsen
there were the olson twins
though elizabeth rose to fame all on her
own her sisters the 90s icons mary kate
and ashley became stars
sharing the role of michelle tanner in
the sitcom full house little elizabeth
hadn't even been born yet when the show
began
it didn't stop her from snagging a small
part on the series finale though as
girl with flowers she was already
familiar with the business since a year
prior
she'd also appeared in the olsen twin
flick how the west was fun
as girl in car even though these were
technically her acting debuts
olson doesn't consider this time the
beginning of her career as she was only
really cast since she happened to be
around with her sisters there is one
unique tie the actress has with full
house's michelle tanner though
her middle name is elizabeth which was
likely a tribute to the littlest olson
so like the actual experience of doing
it i don't remember so much
the avengers wasn't olson's first
experience with cgi
it was actually while shooting the 2014
film godzilla
though there was no green screen to be
seen for that movie it was just a lot of
specific eye lines and imagination in a
process that olson described as magic
of course in avengers she dove into a
world of very complex cgi
especially for these fiery scenes
after this for someone who wasn't very
active on social media and
only joined instagram in 2017 olson was
surprisingly convincing playing the
popular influencer taylor in the film
ingrid goes west
last one the actress was actually
shocked to find out that being an
influencer is an actual career
it's surprising to learn that with how
much of her life has been spent in the
public eye
the life of her character wasn't really
something she was able to connect with
goes to show just how skilled an actor
she actually is
try one with the peace sign yeah
considering olson does so many intense
and psychologically demanding roles
this was quite a change from her norm
olson played the love interest of josh
radner who also wrote and directed the
film
the two performers happened to have the
same agent and when the agent had read
the first part of the script
she felt olson would be perfect for the
part and suggested her to radnor
it took a year and a half but the actors
finally met and a week later olsen was
given the role
in the film the two are meant to have
shared a 16-year age gap which
actually wasn't too far off from reality
since the actors
do have a 14-year age gap between them
jesse hand me that lemonade
this 2011 film marked what olson felt to
be the true beginning of her career
and has widely considered her breakout
role having received the part and
finding so much success so soon after
finishing school
olson was thrown into the industry with
multiple offers coming her way
looking back the actress said that if
she'd worked more before the role of
martha
she probably would have been choosier
with the roles that she took
people don't need careers people should
just exist
this facebook watch tv series is the
first in which olsen actually had a
leading role
olson was praised for her nuanced and
thoughtful performance
and the show itself was well reviewed
but despite all of this
it didn't really gain much of a
viewership and only ran from 2018 to
2019
though we are glad she's free now to be
wanda maximoff
you have to be there definitely not a
show with a small audience
he needed a distraction olson suited up
and went through rigorous training to
take on the role of an fbi rookie in the
murder mystery wind river
after doing six months of self-defense
training and three months of weapon
training the hard work wasn't over
olsen and the crew were working under
extremely tough weather conditions
leaving the actress tired and always
feeling like she had a
very good day at work this was a role
that really excited her because it's not
one that she ever thought would have
been written for her
you hear me yeah of course
olson had a wonderful experience working
alongside another one of our favorite
actors
daniel radcliffe in the 2013 film kill
your darlings
in the film radcliffe played alan
ginsberg and olsen
the lover and eventual wife of jack
kerouac edie parker
the actress definitely went the extra
mile to get into character
often showing up to set in 40 styles
outfits reflecting the era the film was
taking place
the police came and took him down to the
tombs peace
love and misunderstanding was the first
job she got out of school
starring alongside jane fonda and
catherine keener
it was a busy year for her since she
started filming for martha marcy mae
marlene
while she was still on set for this film
olson charmed everyone as the nerdy
teenager
in what was called a great feminist film
a solid start to an amazing career on
screen
ask the goddess to bring you i can't do
that
the 2011 remake of the spanish film la
casa muda
was no walk in the park for olsen who
suffered nightmares while filming as a
result of all the dark and creepy
content
on top of long and exhausting days the
actress was also required to cry a lot
in the film
that actually caused her to be sick god
i wish we got it but we didn't so we're
gonna
just do it again elizabeth olsen and
dakota fanning together seems like a
winning combo
but unfortunately the film turned out to
be a bit of a flop
the major flaw was that fanning and
olson weren't quite the right fit for a
pair of naive teenagers
while it wasn't a success it certainly
didn't do any damage to olson's career
not exactly i saw the light features not
one
but two favorites from marvel tom
hiddleston
also known as loki starred alongside
olsen in this film about a famous
country singer hank williams
olsen actually sings in the film as well
even though she sings poorly
it was on purpose for the film now that
we're seeing more crossovers and mcu
happening
maybe olsen and hillston will appear on
screen together again in the new loki
series
what yeah i'll tell you what sometimes
life just works out the way it's
supposed to it definitely did for olson
when she was cast in this psychological
thriller alongside robert de niro
she happened to be studying psychology
at the time at nyu
even though she acted alongside de niro
in the film olson said she'd never
approach him in the street due to her
social anxiety which
causes her to become nervous with
colleagues when she isn't in some kind
of work environment with them
where'd it go lift your class please
this film was one that
really excited olson when she read it so
much so that she sought out the film so
she could be part of it
the movie is a remake of a south korean
film but olsen actually had no idea it
wasn't an original film when she read it
if you've seen the movie you'll notice
she has lots of tattoos
olson got to have some input on them and
chose to include an octopus tattoo
as a nod to the original film in it her
character had to eat an octopus
let's just say she wasn't too upset that
she didn't have to do the same
which is important for lots of reasons
in secret was the first film to bring
olsen from the art house indie scene to
the multiplex
the film is based on the book terestra
by emile zola
and when olsen was sent the script by
the producer mickey liddell she was
taking a class in university called
realism and naturalism and theater
her first assignment for the class was
reading that book and the play that it's
based on
not only did she love the film script
but she found a new appreciation for the
whole project academically as well
the stars definitely aligned for this
one there were a couple specific moments
where i was kind of pinching myself at
night being like that
that was awesome it's incredible to
think of how varied a career olson has
had in a fairly
short period of time now we've got some
great content to check out while we're
waiting for the scarlet witch to take
the screen again in doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness
you